Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous.
Je suis là, devant vous, immobile.
Immobile comme vous,
immobile par rapport à vous.
Et comme vous le savez,
il faut se méfier des apparences.
C’est en tout cas ce que pensait un
certain Albert Einstein qui, en 1905,
a démontré que, quand on
est immobile dans l’espace,
en fait, on va très vite
dans l’espace-temps.
En fait, on fonce à la vitesse de
la lumière dans l’espace-temps.
Sa théorie, qu’on appelle
la théorie de la relativité restreinte,
stipule en effet que tout va tout
le temps à la vitesse de la lumière
dans l’espace-temps.
C’est-à-dire qu’à chaque seconde,
vous comme moi,
nous parcourons dans l’espace-temps
300 000 km.
Et sa théorie énonce également que,
lorsqu’on se déplace dans l’espace,
en fait, on change la direction de
notre trajectoire dans l’espace-temps,
et que, ce faisant, on diminue la vitesse
avec laquelle on va vers le futur.
Autrement dit, se déplacer dans l’espace,
c’est ralentir la vitesse
avec laquelle on prend de l’âge.
En d’autres termes,
aller vite dans l’espace,
c’est finalement lutter
contre le vieillissement.
Mais évidemment, il ne faut pas rêver,
ce n’est pas
avec des petits footings à 15 km/h
qu’on peut espérer jouer sur ce tableau.
Mais ça me semble être
une leçon intéressante
de considérer que la seule façon
de maximiser la vitesse avec laquelle
on va vers le futur, c’est l’immobilité.
Évidemment, ce qu’on appelle
la course contre la montre -
le sujet d’aujourd’hui -
c’est tout à fait autre chose.
Ce qu’on appelle la course contre
la montre, c’est le fait d’être pressé.
Très bien.
Mais il faut être précis
à propos de se presser.
C’est-à-dire qu’il faut savoir
de quoi l’on parle.
Et donc mon propos ce soir
sera de réfléchir avec vous
si nos façons de dire,
en l’occurrence cette course
contre la montre,
reflètent ou trahissent
nos façons de vivre ?
La première chose qu’on peut remarquer,
c’est qu’être pressé, ce n’est pas
la même chose que se hâter.
On se hâte quand on fait
prestement mouvement
vers un but singulier qu’on a choisi.
Autrement dit, on est tiré, aspiré,
vers l’objectif qu’on désire.
Et donc, la hâte a toujours à voir
avec l’impatience, avec l’élan,
avec l'excitation parfois.
C’est d’ailleurs très simple :
on se hâte quand on a hâte.
C’est la hâte que nous éprouvons
qui détermine la hâte de nos activités.
Et donc la hâte est toujours dynamique,
dynamisante, et elle peut être joyeuse,
alors qu’être pressé,
c’est tout à fait autre chose.
Le fait d’être pressé n’est pas
le résultat d’un désir,
mais au contraire d’une contrainte,
d’une obligation.
On n’est pas aspiré par l’échéance,
on est poussé vers elle,
souvent contre son gré et parfois
avec un sentiment de faute.
Avec l’idée que si on échoue,
alors on sera éjecté de sa propre vie.
Comme si le fait d'échouer,
en l’occurrence de ne pas
arriver à vaincre le temps,
faisait que notre vie n’était pas méritée.
Nous ne méritons notre vie que
si nous la menons tambour battant,
à bout de souffle en quelque sorte.
Et cette course contre la montre,
elle peut nous consumer, nous brûler -
c’est ce qu’on appelle le burn out -
mais elle peut aussi,
quand elle est maîtrisée,
nous donner le sentiment
d'exister davantage.
L’urgence -
Il y a une sorte griserie cinétique.
Il y a une sorte de jouissance authentique
au fait d’être pressé.
Dans les hôpitaux,
il y a des services dits d’urgence.
Mais on peut inverser la proposition
et se rendre compte que
l’urgence nous rend des services
au sens où elle nous fait
nous sentir davantage vivant.
Simplement, il y a des cas où
cette jouissance est tellement
forte qu’elle devient addictive.
Et se sentir pressé comme un citron,
et boire le suc qui en sort,
ça peut être quelque chose qui a
le même effet qu’un produit dopant
et même carrément une drogue.
Et dans tous ces cas qui sont très divers,
on parle de course contre la montre.
Je vais faire quelque chose que je
ne dois pas faire, c’est sortir des notes.
Je n’ai pas eu le temps
de réviser mon texte,
mais comme je suis dans une école
où je suis professeur,
j’estime que j’ai le droit
de faire le mauvais élève.
Donc, la question est :
on parle de course contre la montre,
est-ce que c’est la bonne façon de dire ?
Quand on dit ça, on sous-entend,
de façon implicite donc,
que la montre serait
l’emblème suprême du temps,
que la montre serait un objet
plus temporel que tous les autres.
On croit même que, quand
la montre s’arrête, le temps s’arrête.
Et donc la montre est ce qui incarne
à nos yeux le temps même.
Mais est-ce qu’on a raison de croire
que le temps montre
une présence plus forte
dans tout ce qui relève de l’horlogerie ?
Posons la question sérieusement :
que montre une montre ?
« Ben du temps »,
répondent sans hésitation
ceux qui ont la langue bien pendule,
tel un certain Martin Heidegger,
grand philosophe qui dit toujours
des choses avec des mots compliqués,
qui prétendait, lui,
que le temps se donne à voir,
je le cite, « dans la présentification
de l’aiguille qui avance ».
Mais est-ce qu’il avait raison ?
Est-ce que les montres montrent le temps ?
Bien sûr que non.
Elles le travestissent
en modifiant son essence.
C’est-à-dire qu’elles nous conduisent
à l’assimiler
au mouvement parfaitement
régulier de l’aiguille.
Et ce faisant, elles montrent non pas
le temps même, mais un avatar de l’espace,
une doublure de la cinématique.
Alors, vous me direz :
« Oui, mais les horloges, les montres
mesurent également des durées. »
Non, le fait de représenter les durées
par le biais d'un mouvement spatial
masque, même si c’est convaincant,
le moteur caché,
qu’on appelle justement le temps,
qui fait que chaque instant présent,
dès qu’il se présente, est remplacé
par un autre instant présent,
qui prend donc sa place,
et qui lui-même devra se retirer aussitôt
pour laisser la place au suivant.
Et c’est le moteur de ce renouvellement
permanent qu’on appelle le temps.
Est-ce qu’il est montré par les montres ?
Non.
Et donc, la conclusion, c’est que
les montres ne montrent pas le temps.
On peut le dire d’une façon
plus agréable à l’oreille :
le temps loge hors de l’horloge.
C’est-à-dire qu’il n’y a pas
plus de temps dans les montres
qu’il n’y en a à l’extérieur des montres.
Ça veut dire que, en fait,
nous ne percevons jamais le temps,
nous ne le voyons jamais
comme un phénomène brut.
Nous ne voyons que ses effets,
ses habits, ses atours,
toutes sortes de choses qui nous trompent
sur sa véritable nature.
Mais ce qu’on comprend ensemble
en disant cela,
c’est que ce qu’on appelle abusivement
une course contre la montre,
en fait, c’est une course qu’on mène,
à l’intérieur du temps même,
contre le temps, tout contre même.
Je dirais même tellement tout contre
qu’on ne peut aller ni plus vite que lui,
ni moins vite que lui.
Alors le temps, c’est un sujet
qui aujourd’hui est très à la mode.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez ce poème
d’André Breton, « Le verbe être ».
C’est un poème, si ma mémoire est bonne -
non pas que j’étais né à l’époque,
mais si la mémoire
que j’ai de mes lectures est juste -
qui a été écrit dans les années 30.
Et ce poème contient cette phrase :
« Il fait un temps de temps. »
Bon. Cette phrase est
encore plus vraie aujourd’hui.
Il fait vraiment un temps de temps.
On a l'impression que le temps, c'est la
grande préoccupation de notre époque.
J’en veux pour preuve
qu’on organise de multiples colloques
qui interrogent la nature du temps.
Mais il faut être honnête.
Nous parlons du temps,
nous méditons sur le temps,
sans jamais trop savoir
à quel type d’entité nous avons affaire.
Est-ce que le temps est une substance ?
Est-ce que c’est un fluide ?
Est-ce que c’est une entité physique ?
Est-ce que c’est le paramètre t ?
Est-ce que c’est simplement un mot ?
Est-ce que c’est un produit
de la conscience ?
Ou de la psyché ?
Ça fait un peu plus sérieux.
Est-ce que c’est un produit culturel
ou un produit de la culture ?
Toutes ces thèses, toutes ces hypothèses
sont défendues ici ou là.
Il y a même des gens qui pensent
que le temps est une illusion.
Et sans doute sont-ils
encouragés inconsciemment -
je veux dire, à l’insu de leur plein gré -
par une anagramme, l’anagramme de
« Le temps est une illusion ».
Prenez les lettres, vous changez l’ordre,
et si vous avez de la chance,
vous tomberez sur l’anagramme :
« où se pillent les minutes ».
« Le temps est une illusion
où se pillent les minutes. »
Ce sont les mêmes lettres
dans un autre ordre.
Je pense que cette anagramme résume
assez bien le sujet qui nous rassemble -
la course du temps -
même si, s’il est vrai
que le temps est une illusion,
on ne voit pas très bien
ce qu’on pourrait piller à l’intérieur.
C’est devenu une banalité :
on constate aujourd’hui
que l’urgence s’est liquéfiée.
Elle s'infiltre partout.
Elle colonise tous les aspects de la vie,
notamment des personnes les plus actives,
et nous-mêmes constatons
que nos agendas sont sursaturés,
que nous sommes des cyber-Gédéon
ou des turbo-Bécassine.
Comme le disait Gilles Châtelet, un
mathématicien venu donner quelques cours
à l’École centrale
il y a quelques années :
« Constatant que tout fonce,
à commencer par nous-même,
nous nous exclamons :
′ Le temps s’accélère. ′
comme si le temps épousait
le rythme de nos trépidations,
comme si le temps suivait les trépidations
de notre emploi du temps,
comme si le temps nous courait après,
un peu énervé,
armé d’une pique ou d’une fourche
pour nous châtier. »
Il y a là quelque chose d’assez bizarre :
nous n’hésitons pas à parler du temps
comme s’il avait une vitesse,
voire une accélération.
Vous êtes bien placés
pour savoir qu’une vitesse,
c’est une dérivée par rapport au temps.
Donc, comment est-ce qu’on pourrait
définir la vitesse du temps ?
Il faudrait dire : « Comment est-ce
que le cours du temps s’écarte
du cours du temps ? »
c’est-à-dire « s’écarte de lui-même »,
et ça ne pourrait se dire
que par le biais d’une tautologie.
On dirait par exemple :
« Le temps est cette chose mystérieuse
qui avance de vingt-quatre heures
toutes les vingt-quatre heures. »
Et on serait bien avancé.
Donc le concept de temps -
ou de vitesse du temps plutôt -
n’a aucun sens.
Pas plus que le concept
d’accélération du temps n’en aurait.
Une seconde d’aujourd’hui dure exactement
la même durée qu’il y a 20 ans.
D’ailleurs,
la seconde se définit très
exactement par le fait
qu’elle dure très exactement une seconde.
N’empêche que
le succès de cette expression fautive -
« le temps s’accélère » -
en dit long sur le rapport que
nous entretenons avec notre époque.
Proclamer que la vitesse du temps augmente
sous prétexte que le rythme
et la quantité d’informations,
d’échanges, d’interactions
que nous pouvons avoir,
c’est fabriquer un raccourci très trompeur
qui vient insidieusement
modifier le rapport psychique
que nous avons avec le présent.
Nous nous sentons en retard par rapport à
je ne sais quel rythme qu’aurait le monde,
une sorte de rythme propre
qui serait le rythme du monde
vis-à-vis duquel nous ne pourrions
être qu’en retard.
Et ce retard irrattrapable,
évidemment, il nous culpabilise.
Il faut que je mette
mes notes à l’endroit.
On a toujours l’impression de stagner,
d’être en retard par rapport au monde,
sans être capable de dire ce qui détermine
cette cadence folle
que nous croyons devoir suivre.
En réalité, nous sommes
beaucoup moins victimes
d’une prétendue accélération du temps
que d’une superposition
de présents multiples.
Tandis que nous travaillons
avec notre ordinateur,
nous consultons notre téléphone,
nous écoutons la radio,
en regardant des vidéos
tout en pensant à autre chose.
Et quand nous sommes capables
psychiquement de gérer
cette multitude de stimuli,
ou d’injonctions
qui peuvent être contradictoires,
nous avons le sentiment d’exister
davantage, d’être important.
On gère.
Au contraire, quand on est dépassé,
on est complètement écrasé
par le fait qu’on n’arrive plus à définir,
parmi toutes les choses qui nous incombe,
qu’on nous demande, une priorité.
Et il ne faut pas oublier que tout le
monde ne court pas au même rythme.
Tandis que certains se consument
dans cette course contre la montre
dont on parle,
d’autres s’ennuient à mourir,
D’autres encore, parfois les mêmes,
trouvent le temps de passer cinq
heures par jour devant la télévision.
Et donc,
en matière d’intensité existentielle,
nous sommes très, très loin de l’égalité.
Pensez à la vie, au rapport
au temps des prisonniers,
des malades, des vieillards.
En théorie de la relativité,
comme je l’ai dit,
le décalage des horloges résulte
de leur mouvement relatif dans l’espace.
Quand on se déplace
par rapport à quelqu’un,
le temps qu’on emporte avec soi
se désynchronise de celui
de la personne qu’on a laissée.
Mais ce ne sont pas
nos déplacements relatifs
qui créent le fait qu’aujourd’hui, nous
ne sommes que très rarement synchrones.
Vous pouvez être ensemble
à plusieurs au même endroit,
sans être pour autant
connectés au présent
de la même façon.
Chacun pourra vivre selon son
propre temps propre, si j’ose dire,
en choisissant ce à quoi
il va porter attention,
ce à quoi il va s’occuper.
Autrement dit, notre société,
grâce aux appareils portatifs
que nous avons tous,
a pu fabriquer ce que j’appellerais
une entropie chrono-dispersive :
chacun peut désynchroniser
son temps propre de celui des autres
par le seul fait qu’il a les moyens
de singulariser par rapport aux autres
ce qui va attirer son attention.
Et ça m’amène à dire que quand nous disons
aujourd’hui : « Je n’ai pas le temps »,
très souvent, nous mentons.
Je veux dire par là que nous,
nous avons une espérance de vie
beaucoup plus grande que nos ancêtres.
Et dans cette longue durée de vie
que nous avons,
les temps de loisirs sont
beaucoup plus importants
que ceux dont disposaient nos ancêtres.
Mais la raison principale, c'est justement
que nous avons du temps libre,
beaucoup de temps libre.
Et le temps libre,
c’est ce à l’intérieur
de quoi on est libre.
Et donc quand vous dites :
« Je n’ai pas le temps »,
vous dites en réalité quelque chose
qui n’a rien à voir avec le temps,
qui a seulement à voir avec le fait
que vous affirmez votre liberté.
Si un ami - ou votre patron -
vous demande de faire quelque chose -
plutôt un ami d’ailleurs -
quand vous lui dites : « Je n’ai pas le
temps », ce que vous voulez dire, c’est :
« Mon ami, j’ai tout à fait le temps
de faire autre chose que
ce que tu me demandes.
Et donc, tu ne vas pas venir déranger
la liberté que je me suis choisie. »
Encore une fois, il faut être honnête,
nous ne nous laisserions pas
déborder autant
si nous n’aimons pas cela au moins un peu.
Et donc, quand on cède si facilement
à quelque chose
dont on se plaint par ailleurs,
c’est sans doute qu’il y a un peu
de métaphysique cachée là-derrière.
Il suffit de nous observer.
Quand nous sommes coincés
dans les embouteillages,
nous pestons à l’idée
que des morceaux entiers de temps
nous passent sous le nez sans
qu’on puisse en tirer le moindre profit.
Nous sommes exaspérés
par tous les frottements du quotidien,
car du temps vécu, nous voudrions occuper
tous les instants d’une façon rentable.
Puisque nous ne sommes
rien d’autre que notre vie,
il y a urgence à la réussir,
à lui trouver un sens.
Il s’agit donc de n’être jamais inerte
et de se donner corps et âme
à l’imminence du futur.
En fait, je crois profondément que
si nous cédons si volontiers à l'urgence,
c’est tout simplement parce qu’elle nous
donne le sentiment de densifier
nos existences.
L’urgence nous leste,
elle nous ancre dans le réel.
Elle nous ontologise, en quelque sorte.
Je me garderais de conclure
d’une façon trop ferme.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ces choses-là
ne sont pas simples.
Par exemple, il arrive que la vitesse
soit vécue comme un remède frontal
contre l’urgence.
Je pense au TGV.
Est-ce que vous avez remarqué
que dans les TGV,
les visages des voyageurs sont sereins ?
Comme si le fait de savoir,
et non pas de sentir, qu’on va très vite,
permettait enfin de prendre son temps.
Il y avait d’ailleurs un slogan
publicitaire de la SNCF,
qui a été abandonné depuis, mais qui
était une sorte d’injonction paradoxale.
Le slogan, c’était, pour vanter le TGV :
« Prenez le temps d’aller vite. »
C’était assez subtil parce que
nous avons tendance à associer
la tranquillité d’esprit
à la lenteur, à la léthargie.
Ce qu’a compris la SNCF, c’est que,
quand on fonce dans un TGV,
en fait, on fonce calmement, sans hâte,
comme si le principe d’inertie
ne s’incarnait vraiment qu’au-delà
de 300 kilomètres par heure.
Au fond de nous-mêmes,
nous savons que l’agitation n’est pas
le plus court chemin vers la création.
La création suppose ce que Paul Valéry
appelait des loisirs non chronométriques.
Pour être créatif, il ne faut pas
être pris par la montre.
En préparant rapidement
cette intervention,
victime que j’étais
d’une course contre la montre,
j’ai trouvé une lettre écrite
par le peintre Fernand Léger
qu’il adresse à son ami
Le Corbusier, grand architecte,
dans laquelle il explique
que les choses importantes
ne se font que si elles sont imprégnées
de lenteur et de recul.
Je le cite :
« La vie sérieuse, écrit-il, marche
à trois kilomètres à l’heure,
c’est-à-dire au pas d’une vache
sur une route.
Le danger d’une vie comme la nôtre,
c’est de croire aux 1 200 km/h de l’avion
et de penser que ce truc-là change
quoi que ce soit à la création,
que celle-ci soit artistique
ou scientifique.
La création est toujours contrainte par
la règle des grandes forces naturelles.
Un arbre met dix ans à devenir un arbre,
et un grand tableau, et un beau roman,
et une belle invention,
du 3 km/h, monsieur, et encore. »
Nous sommes tous conscients
de la vérité de cette vérité,
et c’est pourquoi chacun d’entre nous,
régulièrement,
se prend à rêver d’un monde intemporel
où il pourrait s’épanouir et inventer
à l’abri des soubresauts
de l’empressement.
La question est :
« En pratique, comment faire ? »
Je n’ai pas de solution, je n’ai pas
de recette personnelle à vous livrer,
mais je connais quelqu’un
qui prétend avoir trouvé une solution.
Ce quelqu'un s'appelle Erwin Schrödinger,
qui était l'homme d'une équation célèbre
et de plusieurs femmes.
La superposition quantique,
il savait ce que c’était.
Il prétendait avoir trouvé une solution
pour arrêter la course contre le temps.
Il dit : « Pour cela, il suffit
d’un baiser sincère. »
Je le cite :
« Aimez une fille de tout votre cœur
et embrassez-la sur la bouche.
Alors, dit-il, le temps s’arrêtera
et l’espace cessera d’exister. »
Je vous laisse chacune et chacun d’entre
vous juger, pour son propre compte,
à condition que ce ne soit pas
un compte Tweeter,
de la pertinence de cette recette.
Je vous remercie d’avoir pris le temps
d’écouter ma course contre la montre
dont j’espère vous avoir démontré
qu’elle n’en était pas une.
Et d’ailleurs, si je puis me permettre,
vous n’avez pas pris le temps,
c’est le temps qui vous a pris.
(Applaudissements)